on va continuer à dérouler la carrière
de jean-paul belmondo mais on a en ligne
adil rami qui était un ami jean paul
belmondo a dit vous ne nous entendez oui
très bien merci merci
à lui cela nous donne pas la peine de
faire ça lui
8 ova
adil comment vous avez rencontré jean
paul belmondo on connaît ça on connaît
sa passion pour la boxe on était un peu
au courant pour le pour le football mais
comment vous vous avez fait sa
connaissance
adil hadi les hors-jeu déjà
mais dès qu'il m'a attendu laraque aussi
je crois on voulait qu'ils appellent
directement
quelqu'un arrive chez lui on va on va
leur prendre des rétabli la deal qui
était très direction de lille non
ça lui a dit on en était resté à savoir
comment vos combats vous aviez fait la
connaissance leur goal
bayreuth inquiète pas mon ami là ça va
on est on est amis suite offrira un
téléphone prochainement
à l'entraînement à l'appui que marseille
on était tous se bat tous choqués de le
voir parce que jamais je n'aurais pu
penser un jour rencontré jean paul ii le
monde à ce moment là
derrière derrière gerlache j'ai parlé
avec pièce et lui dire que la guerre est
de le rencontrer dans un restaurant
privé ce dixième rétro il rentre à la
maison et prendre à la maison j'en ai
parlé à l'époque à montech et pamela et
quand je lui parle de double mais moi je
pensais pas c'est pas qui était connu
dans le monde entier comme ça elle me
dit mais ce qui est incroyable c'est un
rêve pour moi de le rencontrer ma
chambre j'ai voulu par plaisir aussi à
pas mais à l'époque et du coup je lui ai
dit bon bah allez on va le voir et mais
j'étais j'étais choquée j'ai déjeuné
quand je l'avais vu jadis faut dire bah
oui c'est moi qui ai dit et qui n'était
comme un fou à lille parce que même moi
il m'a envoyé un sms avec une photo de
jean paul il m'a dit je suis en train de
manger avec jean-paul il le fait déjà
mais parce que quand il mangeait avec
d'autres personnes ils me voient pas de
sms est comme un fou hehy me viens nous
rejoindre c'est vrai qu'il était
vraiment fan malade il a dit vous vous
connaissiez vous connaissiez l'acteur
mais comment vous avez trouvé l'homme
quel homme vous avez découvert
super super marrant et adoré blague et
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs de lui avec
des avec des fous rires
me rappelle quand je suis arrivé chez
lui la première fois à cannes bat son
chien il a géré le chopper et la iv ème
fois pendant une bonne demi heure un peu
vieux jeu pourtant j'aime courir après
parce que les tahitiens mais voilà le
souvenir que j'ai de g2 de jean paul et
puis à chaque fois quand j'avais
l'opportunité la page reste avec dia
jette avec jean-paul et puis publiées
mais les brumes hajime petite blague
mais ceux qui adorent et ça mais mais
c'est vrai que j'ai un bon là je me
rendais compte de la chance que j'avais
il voulait en profiter un maximum alors
merci d'y être pour toi toi même pour
tous les moments il avait pratiqué le
football c'était resté un vrai foot et
vous parliez foot avec lui ou
voulez-vous parler cinéma et
il parlait plus de pamela adil
inde il a raccroché donc ma question
n'aura pas répondu jean-paul regarder
plus pamela quasi l'agglo c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai mais je voudrais dire à
grade il s'était vraiment un événement
pour lui de rencontrer jean-paul je vous
jure parce que il m'a vraiment je te dis
moi il m'a envoyé à chaque fois qu'il
voyait jean paul bailly m'envoyer une
photo et jean paul donc jusqu'au voilà
pas vous [ __ ] là il
est
juste je tiens à dire quelque chose
c'est quand adil rami tête avec pamela
anderson il a présenté tout le monde ce
que même moi il m'a invité aussi à aller
prendre un verre avec lui voilà et donc
voilà je dirais que jean paul était très
content de rencontrer pas mais l'art je
crois et je voulais voir effet juste
faire une petite parenthèse c'est qu'un
jour a dit nous à nous inviter à saint
tropez comme ça faisait beaucoup de
route pour jean-paul hadid a eu
l'élégance de lui envoyer un hélicoptère
ah ouais et adil hadi je vais essayer
d'accrocher mais
les gens qu'il veut
a dit la banque avant que sa coupe une
deuxième fois je vous demandais si
belmondo aussi qu'il a pratiqué le
football est ce qu il était resté
vraiment fan de foot a foutu ce que vous
parliez football avec lui oui je te
rendrai à l'époque où j'étais tellement
la vie à voir tous les jours voilà les
filières et il voulait pas que j'arrête
ils en parlaient adf est une idée alors
qu'est ce qu'il va faire voir ce qu'il
va aller tiens au courant donc il
voulait vraiment il était vraiment très
très intéressé depuis la mi-mars mais
manque de bol regardez regardez l'équipe
il s'intéresser au score les matchs de
l'équipe de france pasta passerait de
sport et de foot aussi mais merci
d'avoir été là verso merci a dit merci
vous ne sauriez vous je t'embrasse mont
faron d'amour la fille